you know if you've been following my
stuff over the last 34 years especially
last couple years like I speak about
reverse engineering all the time to
reverse engineer reverse engineer
reverse engineer versus engineer trying
to reverse engineer reverse NGT in the
reverse engineer mo reverse engineer but
just it's how my brain works and I truly
believe it's how a lot of the people
that win do things I do think it's
massively important to know what you're
trying to accomplish
first not waver from that make that the
Northstar cut out all the other [ __ ]
no it's black and white
forget the grey forget the distractions
forget the what-ifs
forget the subjectiveness and address
the finish line and then reverse
engineer it like when you know what you
want when you know where you're going
and you're not emotional about it and
you don't care what other people think
and you don't get distracted you can get
there if you focus on it 24/7 365
forever and so I just want to always
know what the hell I'm focused on and
where I'm going and what I want to want
to do and how do I want in and within
what budget and how and how many and it
just reverse engineer what you want to
happen the problem for so many of you
the reason so few things are happening
for a lot of people is they're confused
they don't know what they want they want
eight thousand things they're just
confused
stop being confused figure out what you
want reverse-engineer it and get it
you